how you doing there reject nation I'm
Greg Alba John I'm John we're gonna
watch a video from gene Jeter it's a
little bit different I hear it's in
regards to the youtuber DAX rap artists
he actually hit me up on Instagram a
little bit ago we were gonna do a
reaction one of his music videos I saw a
couple of his songs and I actually think
it's a pretty good wrapper around that
week something just happened and we just
didn't get around to it so whatever did
it
it's called axe uncovered I don't know
there's gonna be a controversial video
or not waiting to find out it's just a
very artistic
come up documentary perhaps gene Jeter
go check out his YouTube channel we
react to his videos monthly it's a gene
he's a creative fella this guy
no jumper Provost Dex screwed home I
really didn't want to make this video I
didn't I did but my thing is like when
you're a part of the YouTube community
and whether or not that's one's become
older you want to trap or not that's
neither here nor there he's a part of
YouTube community this is where he puts
out his content this is where he's
benefiting there's just a certain code
of conduct that I feel like you need to
go by when you're working with other
content creators it's just like that's
just kind of the way it goes so for
everybody that's wondering like what
you're talking about
my man is ripping people off it's not
cool and I feel like it needs to be
spoken don't be scared of this word word
cloud chaser do what you got to do to
get what you got to get because not
everybody is like not everybody has
someone to co-sign them everybody has a
big-ass back everyone's rich so you've
got to do what you got to do I was broke
I was a janitor so I did what I had to
do to now be able to sit with you
someone had contacted me through Twitter
saying that they had worked with tax in
the past and they had proved this to me
by showing their name in a project that
is still on Dax's channel to this day
and they were also being followed by
Thad who if you don't know that is Dax
is camera man and basically he had said
that Dax actually said this to Thad one
day he told that one day that he could
have had a better job they could pay
more but he thought being a janitor
would be a better story
- dropped the game started I am NOT a
gem oh did I mention I was a janitor
it literally suppose if there is one of
the biggest one in taxes career just
don't do it look through a video and
find one where someone doesn't know did
I mention I was a janitor
I'm dish and you're supposed to be a
cracker on the dish shop I used to be
the district guy so people forgot your
street lacrosse you used to be a tory
lanez just came at this track this guy
is getting a ditch track yes you heard
that right
it's that decided to make it this time
on Tory Lanez
yes we're in 2019 for some reason we're
still trying to diss two lanes like
legit that's put a lot of effort into it
he's in the graveyard and everything
[Laughter]
[Music]
on the same day that Dutch drop the
district on Tory Lanez this happened
commissioner ownership not going Monday
ger
what is she's not going apologize story
what happened Blaine had bought him a
diverse from all the counties named
Derek D the district one of law peeps
close friends before he had died the
first was from a song that Derek took
down almost immediately upload that was
the old forty missed calls while Blaine
was making his new song he got another
rapper on as well named love sad kid but
low peep had sadly passed away before it
was done but they still wanted to
release the song the only thing was that
with the new mix there was an extra spot
on it so ruiner ended up being able to
get Dax actually involved in the project
and got him on the song with the
agreement that the song would be put on
Dax's channel with everyone getting
their proper credit for the work they
put into it ruiner then says that after
a few months of work on the song he
actually was able to get a mix of it
done and given to Blaine who then he had
it mastered decks then asked for the
stems for the song so that he would be
able to get it all approved by Atlantic
for those of you don't know what stems
are they're basically the different
layers that make up the components of a
song Jackson also said that no one was
going to steal anything from Blaine and
then he had absolutely nothing to worry
about
so Blaine thinking that nothing could go
wrong ended up giving the stems to Dax
and then things went wrong
Dax took the little people got a brand
new producer to make a new beat for the
song got the producer to mix low peeps
hook again deleted everybody else's
verses off of the song recorded two new
verses to put on in their spots instead
and to make things worse Dax ended up
actually recording a music video for the
new version of the song and we're peeps
versus were he stole footage from little
peeps photographer and used those you
can literally see the court and they're
like you were breaking the bus
I didn't see that doing the reaction
because I was strictly there for the
balls I was strict me there for the
board well I got a new it's a lot of
stuff I notice about this check here a
minute to a lot of the bad [ __ ] needy
that's tough that's tough
they're not the mention that's when they
caught me with it everybody that reactor
2 reactor so mine will get removed but I
see other youtuber say hey use a YouTube
community
[Music]
like if you cook down your price hey the
connection price now you make you do
this you know you don't have to come
down in your price even so I brother you
just not do it all of them come down on
your price this might even even how
Stephen this bigger than even that it's
like how could you have as your own work
you know so fun it's like wanna give you
a half friends
and I know you got to put it out and be
promoted in now I look bad
oh yeah the work diverse his way I can't
even imagine if somebody was they hit me
up and say now I want to paint you and
then I say yeah it's gonna be $5,000
$10,000 and they said I ain't got it be
nice a [ __ ] they keep dropping he's
like if you don't pay me enough money
then you only get half the gas or
something something stupid like that
listen I'm reading these text messages
with these kids that you talking to home
I'm reading them
you told them a price and I get it don't
get me wrong I couldn't make you for
coming down on that price eating
significantly in some cases but you're
not telling them hey I'm not gonna put a
lot into this hey I'm gonna give you
less bars hey I'm not gonna promote this
you're still leading with the same the
same thing that you told them when you
said 1500 but you're now accepting 250
you're still saying the same stuff
though so you can't lead someone to
believe that and then be like well you
should just know that if you didn't pay
that money you ain't gonna get that much
it's like ah they get you the business
if I went to AT&T and ain't tell me
something that shit's gonna get made
right freestyle first it sounded ready
to go written arrested breastfeed you
own your own track like a similar
freestyle bird sounds better than your
written raps the breastfed you own your
own trail like your simile won't even
make sense because breastfeeding is
breastfeeding Similac expect you like
you can't brush for you somebody similar
some on something like this is the
formula which mean is that bottom even
make sense
breastfeeding is like many holes in this
simple I can't breast milk oh I'll keep
it I know keep it still trying to write
what you do
[Music]
[Music]
and it became price feed.you by similar
white similar you love you reneged on
you reneged on your birth and we were
playing spain you just read
yeah that's what I'm just saying man
listen I don't know there's some kind of
play behind this whatever he was doing
like I think he just thought I don't
know man I don't know I think he I think
in his mind he thought I'm gonna drop
the white ass rappers track it's gonna
get crazy gonna do crazy numbers and I
prepped all these guys that I'm gonna
drop it so they're all gonna have
distance ready and when I drop money
they're all going to respond to me and I
don't think in his mind he thought like
it mattered if theirs was better or
maybe he's just delusional enough to
really think he's better than everybody
he does I don't know I really don't know
but I do think that he thought he would
drop his we would all drop ours and his
name would be all over YouTube to the
point that he would be trending and he
would grow from that oh I almost
guarantee you that that was exactly what
his play was now the fact that some
people staggered out there drop scripted
and driving it even if he does which I
don't know if he will but it's gonna be
a little bit later on like I just don't
think it's working out the way that he
planned it I think he really thought
that in his dick he was gonna gather us
all together and I think he used the
whole Dax nanos thing trying to get us
in the Avengers night State so we're
like yo we all got to come at him
together I just I really I don't know I
just don't think about the way he
guarantee we didn't go to what you
wanted kind of Nick Fury Dan by way of
dr. hmm I just learned a whole lot in a
in a 12 minute window guy whose song as
I've only heard like two about it well
we got to keep in mind this is all very
the one-sided argument here yeah you
know we haven't heard from Dax Miller
from Dax we haven't heard from any of
his defenders haven't heard any of the
diss tracks yeah we haven't heard a lot
of these things react to all of it like
it's easy to go wow this Dax sounds like
a horrible dude you watch stuff it
almost 30-minute compilation
dedicated to a buncha clips about him I
can't defend him because I simply don't
know enough yeah or I can't all I know
is this I recognize eight yeah I'm right
there with these guys cuz I just don't
know enough like honestly there's the
first few minutes I was kind of confused
as to what they were talking about as it
progressed I was like okay I'm latching
on mortal to what's being said the one
thing that I can definitely say that I
agree with is the idea of cause like we
do Randall sometimes and we kind of
treat brand deals the same no matter
what the price is like there are some
brand deals we're literally like the pay
is 100 bucks to do something and then
some brand deals they'll pay us more
than that $40,000 oh yeah and we'll put
the same r-value of effort into the
100's $100 one we'll put a same amount
of work into a 40,000 dollar one as
opposed to the affiliate ones yeah the
percent of what people happen to maybe
want to buy that oh yeah I mean the
amount of loot gaming boxes we haven't
sold compared to the amount of hours
that have spent editing and gaming
staggering numbers those would be yeah
yeah I agree with that that it's not
really about the price especially if
you're getting hired to do a certain
thing you got to put the same amount of
effort into it I mean even them weirdly
like something like this this is a
topper worked here on patreon
less than a hundred bucks but you know
we care we know that this is a
subscriber who is pledge money you put
money down so we're gonna we're gonna do
our best and I know that for this
reaction we're kind of like okay wait a
minute what's going on never assume it's
better just being honest yeah we're
gonna give commentary we're gonna do our
best to get feedback as opposed to just
trying to hype up a reaction so keep it
authentic either way like yeah I agree
if that's is the case and they're
showing these text messages on my side
like I somebody never went through with
doing the music video not because we
thought anything was suspicious about
Dax it just didn't work out that we
scheduled yeah and so because of that we
we didn't do it but you know
reading the messages look like very
similar messages to the ones I had on my
Instagram yeah the guy yeah well I
didn't I mean I didn't know all kinds of
things that were presented here but
there are at least a few things that
touched upon like you know low peep I
was surprised to hear about that
situation because his death was a pretty
big deal and yeah if that's true you
know if he did just kind of take the
stems and completely hijack that track
like that's a crappy thing yeah like
there's no way to justify that no matter
what rate like if anybody's paying you
anything it's like on an ethical level
or a creative level I feel like yeah you
would want to bring your A game to a
track if you're gonna be on it
regardless because every time you appear
yeah is just another business card for
your rapping you know more opportunities
and stuff and like there are huge radio
songs that have lackluster features it's
depressing enough when that happens so
yeah I would be very curious to hear
what any rebuttal to that might sound
like cuz that sounds pretty shady all
the way around you know well integrity
is important you gotta really be able to
lay it out to it especially if you're
gonna be striking up a deal like if you
don't want to do as much because you're
gonna get paid less you just gotta make
that clear yeah like this bat plain and
simple honey you know instead of acting
like you're gonna deliver the same exact
thing for less now on you that's bad but
like I said I haven't heard daksa side I
really don't know I personally hate
being involved in YouTube drama there
was a point in this channel a few years
ago when I was really involved in
something like pretty heavy YouTube
drama and the reaction cancer days that
seems like everyone has pretty much
there was a point where I really felt
that way really hated the drama so I
avoid getting involved in it you know
that's why I'm a lot more careful now
like I'm just giving my honest opinion I
my honest opinion is I can't I don't
feel qualified to give an opinion about
this because I haven't heard both sides
and I can't conclude an opinion and tell
them I can I soak up the drum a G I'm on
social media all day long just drop into
a guy rock I love watch come at me bro I
love watching the drum I really do
just not putting your hand directly onto
the stove yeah very recently there's
that whole thing that is going around
with Collider live about the galaxies oh
yeah which I find very amusing with
Kristian harloff and even in his rant
even to mention real rejects insanely
reactions when you sit down and you do
reactions like when Weil rejects to it
when we do it we weren't like a topic
but we were named her audience act yeah
and so I had some people have you like
you do reaction this is like no I saw
that live and had just my own like wow
this is an interesting afternoon
reaction but yeah I don't want to start
a thing out of that there's also this
weird line because they're talking about
hip hop they're talking about a rack and
a big part of the rap circle lends
itself to this umbrella the zeitgeist of
drama which usually feeling the rap
songs you know and it just seems like
from what it's doing TV was was talking
about you know with the beef kind of
going wrong like he had this plan to
sort of make himself like the Thanos
here so they would all start talking
about which in theory sounds pretty
smart but it just seems like it's all
really backfiring overall has given him
a sort of bad image I don't know the
thing is I don't know what his camp is
like I don't know what his support team
is like you know too so I don't know how
rabid fans are in the other direction of
this I mean it certainly seems like his
plan did something but it does seem kind
of like a version of that something yeah
because whatever is happening right now
it doesn't seem like it's leading to
skyrocketing anything yeah I mean based
off of like looking at Dax's channel he
has a million and a half subscribers and
it seems like all these music videos get
a million or more views you know so he
seems like he's doing something right
yeah I mean even doing this attacking
him for approximately gets people to
check him out well yeah and very far it
doesn't seem like whatever this beef is
has really you know done much damage
yes subscriber counters view is you know
so he listens whatever people come to
the channel for I heard a couple of his
songs I honestly like that so maybe
there are some songs he's ripped off
that I haven't heard those perhaps and I
know there is that file and one of them
was talking about how there's a line
between homage and straight-up just
copying or stealing you that Vanilla Ice
clip those ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding that little bitty
change it's not the same either way this
is interesting
yeah I want to watch more documentaries
about people I've not been exposed to
yet people look out for a redaction
reaction oh yeah yeah oh no way I have a
whole playlist we're gonna use him to
get our channel up to the million
subscriber mark either way this is
promote attacks all right well Jean
thanks for informing us about this yes I
just go check out gene Jeter's channel
he's got a wide variety of videos he's
done he's like try not to laughs he does
his monologues he short films he put up
a try not to laugh or grin her smile
real rejects edition a couple weeks ago
what oh we got a we got a we have the
notification pellon why didn't it show
what I did not know that is sweet so
excited to check that out thanks gene
thanks G everybody go to Gene's channel
and watch the real reach next try not to
laugh see you guys soon